15 minutes you have to go through this
we need 15 months may soon Oh F Ganga
gets impatient with security checks in
Jerusalem but she'd never leave the city
the Palestinian journalists was born
here every day she takes the
20-kilometer trip to work in Ramallah in
the West Bank sometimes she has to wait
an hour at the checkpoint garganta
started a radio station called nice FM
it's the only commercial radio station
aimed at women in the Arab world in many
Arab countries women theoretically enjoy
equal rights with men but many women
regularly complain about sexism and
discrimination the reality for women
here is not what many think gang God
says so it's important for women's
voices to be heard there is a very wrong
impression of Arab woman and possibly
Palestinian woman specifically there's
this stereotype image that an Arab woman
is uneducated and she's like subject of
you
and her her rights are not fulfilled and
so on I believe this is wrong firstly
we're very educated we Palestinian women
have degrees in various fields they fin
lots of them have finished higher
degrees also like masters and PhD and
it's Norman the host of the stations
morning show is a trained journalist I
give you mohabbat littell yet and had
that the young women and two men work
for nisa FM the broadcaster aims to
bring men and women together not cause
controversy but it does brooch taboo
subjects if Abu issue could be for
example abortion in our society we do
have it on air we talk about it but how
we handle it is a little bit like we
we're not going to express opinion that
we as this ifm are in favor of that we
create a discussion between religious
scholars between a psychologist dr. on
that issue the reporters try to include
men's views about half of the stations
listeners are men the station also
focuses on the economic problems in the
region life is constantly getting more
expensive these men say almost one in
five people are unemployed and teachers
have been on strike for the past four
weeks this reporter says women are
accepted here in public but things are
different in the countryside hannah
sibulan mathon what that was recently in
the Jordan Valley far away from Ramallah
I interviewed women there their
situation is really bad whether it's
education culture or the economy they're
controlled by men block the radio
station doesn't just report on the
constraints of tradition it also
features success stories involving
Palestinian women
the broadcaster avoids the political
conflict between Israelis and
Palestinians but it's always on gang
God's mind here and my son is in
Jerusalem and my husband and I are
working in another city it's also very
worrying especially after things that
started happening like I would leave him
and I'm scared like will i know that
i'll go back to Jerusalem that day maybe
the Israelis decide to close the whole
city that there and then what's going to
happen to the boy damn dad says the
constraints on the freedom of movement
make it difficult for women there to get
an education find new jobs and start
businesses but that's all she's saying
on the topic gang God is wary she was
already sent to prison shortly after
founding her first station Ram FM but
does she think women and men different
politics I believe that a woman leader
would have more empathy possibly some
issues would have more sensitivity and
feelings so yes a woman touch in
politics could add value in my opinion
and not just their gang got hopes her
radio station will increase women's
influence in all areas of society